et puis un moment magique à l'hôpital
Clocheville de Tours Lucas magique ne
croyez pas si bien dire l'association
magie à l'hôpital a fêté aujourd'hui le
dixième anniversaire du parrainage
d'Éric Antoine à cette occasion le
célèbre magicien a mis des étoiles dans
les yeux des enfants hospitalisés selon
les médecins ce genre d'opération est
réellement bénéfique pour les patients
un reportage signalé à Turquie
c'est un truc assez dingue tu fais ça
comme ça
un tour après l'autre et toujours les
mêmes réactions les yeux pétillent avec
des sourires jusqu'aux oreilles les
regards sont rivés sur le magicien bien
connu Éric Antoine
j'ai adoré c'était trop cool parce que
c'est incroyable la magie c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on peut apprendre d'un
coussin et là on a quelqu'un qui nous
montre quelque chose qui qui est arrivé
comme ça alors nous on sait pas faire et
là boum ça sera juste nos yeux comme
Manon tous sont charmés par cette habile
mélange d'humour et de magie mission
accomplie pour Eric Antoine par un de
l'association magie à l'hôpital depuis
10 ans Manon
[Rires]
tu peux être angoissé pour quelque chose
et là tu es juste dans la le merveilleux
de du moment et cette petite
transformation pour moi elle est elle
est pragmatique on la sent on la voit et
elle aide évidemment au mieux être le
mot fierté il est chouette je pense
c'est plutôt ça et puis ça me rend
heureux de sentir que mon engagement et
efficace tenter d'offrir une parenthèse
hospitalisée chaque année 5000 jeunes
bénéficient des actions de cette
association tout rangé
on est tellement persuadé avec Eric un
enfant heureux va guérir plus facilement
c'est à dire qu'on va aider à la
guérison va pas guérir évidemment mais
on va aider ces oui dédramatiser le
milieu hospitalier c'est
apporter du rêve à porter de la magie
pour que le moment passe plus vite mieux
la magie comme un super pouvoir capable
d'adoucir le quotidien et parce que deux
anniversaires valent mieux qu'un le mois
prochain l'association fête le 2e rêve
d'enfants réalisés
avec plaisir ma chérie avec plaisir